holy flowers
[Applause]
their majesties
his royal highnesses
distinguished members of the Norwegian committee
of the nobel
[Music]
dear citizens of colombia
citizens of the world ladies and gentlemen
only 6 years ago
we Colombians did not dare to
imagine the end of a war that
we had suffered for half a century
for the vast majority of us
Peace seemed an impossible dream
and so it was for obvious reasons
because very few almost nobody remembered
what it was like to live in a country in peace today
after six years of serious and often
intense difficult negotiations
I can announce to you and the world with
deep humility and gratitude that the
town of colombia
with the support of our friends from all
the planet is making possible what
impossible
the war that caused so much suffering and
anguish to our population throughout
and the width of our beautiful country has
finished
just like life peace is a
process that brings us many surprises
only two months ago the Colombians
and in fact the whole world is
impacted when in a plebiscite
convened to endorse the agreement of
peace with the farc the votes of the no
exceeded by a narrow margin the
yes votes
it was a result that nobody imagined
a week before in Cartagena
we had lit a flame of
hope by signing the agreement in
presence of world leaders and
now suddenly this flame seemed
to become extinct
many of us remember then a passage of
100 years of solitude the masterpiece of
our Nobel Prize Garcia Marquez
that in some way reflected what
was going on
it was as if God had decided to put
to test every capacity for wonder and
keep the inhabitants of Macondo
in a permanent swing between the
joy and disenchantment doubt and
revelation
to the point that no one could
know for sure where were the
limits of reality
we Colombians felt like
inhabitants of macondo
a place not only magical but also
contradictory
as head of state I understood the
significance of this adverse result
and immediately summon a great
national dialogue for union and
reconciliation
I decided to turn this setback into a
opportunity to reach the widest
consensus that would make possible a new
agreement I dedicated myself to listen to
concerns and suggestions from those
they voted no and of those who voted yes and
also from those who did not vote they were
most to achieve a new and better
I agree an agreement that all Colombia
I could support
it had not been four days since the
surprising plebiscite when the committee
Norwegian announced a decision equally
surprising about the granting of
Nobel Peace Prize
and I must confess
that this news came as a gift
from the sky
at a time when our boat
it seemed to drift
the Nobel prize was the stern wind
what prompted us
to reach our destination the port
of peace thank you very much thank you
Thank you
thank you very much for this vote of
confidence and faith in my future
country
today distinguished committee members
Norwegian I come to tell you to
you and through you to the community
international that we achieved we got to
port today we have in Colombia a new
agreement for the termination of
armed conflict with the farc that welcomes
most of the proposals that we
made
this new agreement was signed two years ago
weeks and the week was endorsed
passed by the congress of the republic
by an overwhelming majority so that
begin to join our
normativity
the long-awaited process of
implementation has already started with the contribution
priceless of the united nations'
with this new agreement ends the
older armed conflict and the last
of the Western Hemisphere
with this agreement as Alfred ordered
nobel in his testament begins the
dismantling an army in this
case an irregular army and its
conversion into a political movement
legal
with this agreement we can say that
america from alaska to patagonia
it is a zone of peace
and we can ask ourselves a bold question
if the war
may end up in a hemisphere because
can not someday both hemispheres
be free of it
maybe today more than ever we can
dare to imagine a world without
war
the impossible can be possible
alfred nobel the great visionary whose
legacy brings us together today
on the exact day when 120 are met
years of his death
wrote sometime
that war is the horror of the
horrors the greatest of crimes
the war can not be in any way
an end in itself
it's just a medium and a medium that
we should always try to avoid
I have been a leader in times of war
to defend freedom and rights
of Colombians
and I've been a leader to make peace
that's why I can tell you from experience
own that is much harder to do the
peace to make war
when it is necessary we must be
prepared to fight and to me
corresponded
as defense minister and as
president fight the armed groups
illegal in my country and I did it with
effectiveness and forcefulness when
paths of peace were closed
however it is foolish to think that the
end of conflicts be the extermination
of the counterpart
the final victory for weapons when
there are non-violent alternatives is not
other than the defeat of the spirit
human
beat by arms annihilate the
enemy bring the war to their
last consequences
is to give up to see in the opposite to
another human being to someone with whom
can you talk
and dialogue
respecting the dignity of all that is
what we did in colombia
and that's why I have the honor of being today
here sharing what we learned in
our hard experience
the first step 1 crucial
was to stop seeing the guerrillas as
enemies
to consider them simply as
adversaries
the general valencia tovar álvaro
valencia tovar who was commander
of the army of colombia historian and
humanist taught me this difference he
he said that the word enemy
it has a connotation of passional struggle
and hate that does not correspond to honor
military
Humanizing the war is not only limiting
its cruelty but also recognize in the
contricante to a similar to a being
human
historians calculate that during
the 20th century they died up to 187 million
of people because of the wars 187
millions
each of them was a human life
priceless someone loved by his family
and your loved ones
and tragically the account keeps growing
in this century
it is good to remember now the incisive
question of bob dylan
my colleague at the reception of the prize
nobel this year
that moved us so much in the years
sixties to those of us who were young
so
how many more deaths will be necessary
until we understand that they have died
too many
the answer to my friend
it goes flying with the wind
the answer my friend is blowing in the
wind spline with the wind
when they asked me if I aspired to
prize
I always answered that it was for me
the real prize
the peace of my country because that is the
true prize the peace of my country
and that peace is not from a president or from
a government but of all the people
Colombian, we have to build it
among all
that's why this award I receive on behalf
of about 50 million Colombians
my compatriots
who finally see a nightmare
of more than half a century that only brought
pain misery and backwardness to our nation
and the receipts mostly on behalf of
the victims of more than 8 million
victims and displaced persons whose lives have
been devastated by the armed conflict
and more than 220,000 women, men and children
that to our shame they have been
killed in this war
the experts tell me that the process of
Peace in Colombia is the first in
world that he has put in the center of his
solution to victims and their rights
We advance this negotiation by making a
great emphasis on human rights
and from this we are very proud
the victims want justice
but more than anything they want the truth
and they want with a generous spirit that they do not
there are new victims who suffer what
They suffered
the professor ronald hitfix founder of
school leadership center
Kennedy of Government of the University of
harvard where I graduated from gave me a
wise advice
He told me when he feels discouraged
tired pessimist always talk to the
victims are they who will give
encouragement and strength to continue
and that's always been the way I could talk to
the victims of this war and I listened
its heartbreaking stories
some of them are here today
reminding us why it is so important
that we build a stable peace and
durable
I would like to ask the victims here
present on behalf of the
victims of the armed conflict in
colombia that stand up so that
receive the homage they deserve
liner palaces lane the palaces is a
of those victims on May 2 of the year
a rudimentary mortar thrown by the
farc in the middle of a fight with the
paramilitaries
He fell in the church of his people there
where its inhabitants had searched
refuge
Nearly 80 women men died and
children most children in question
seconds
Leiner lost 32 family members
his parents and three younger siblings
the farc have asked forgiveness for this
atrocious fact and leiner that is now a
community leader has forgiven them
and that is the great paradox with which I
I have found while many who have not
suffered in the flesh the conflict
resist peace are the victims the
victims the most willing to forgive
reconcile and face the future with
a heart free of hate
This prize also belongs to the
men and women that with huge
patience and strength negotiated in the
habana during all these years they
they reached an agreement that today we can
offer as a model for the solution of
the armed conflicts that subsist in
the planet
and I mean both the negotiators
of the government here present as to the
of the farc my adversaries who
they demonstrated a great will for peace
I want to exalt that will of
embrace to achieve peace because without
she the process would have failed
and I also dedicate this award to the
heroes of the armed forces of
Colombia
they have never stopped protecting the
Colombian people and they understood very well
that the true victory of all
soldier and of all police is peace
and I want to do
a special recognition
all the gratitude of my heart to me
family to my wife and my children without
whose love support this task would have
been much heavier
I share
and finally this prize with the
international community
that with generous and unanimous enthusiasm
I support the peace process from its
the beginning
and let me take this opportunity
to thank very especially
to the Norwegian people
to his government for its peaceful nature and
your spirit of solidarity
It was because of these virtues that they do not see
He entrusted them with the promotion of peace in
world
and I must say that in the case of my country
they fulfilled their work with great
effectiveness
Norway and Cuba in their role as guarantors
chile and venezuela as US escorts
and the European Union with envoys
special all the countries of america
latina and the caribbean
even china and russia
everyone has reasons to participate in the
pride for this achievement
the institute crowd of studies
international peace of the university
de notre damme in the USA concluded after
a detailed study of the 34 agreements
signed in the world in the last three
decades to end conflicts
armed that the peace agreement in
Colombia is the most complete and comprehensive
of all
the peace agreement in colombia 'is a
ray of hope in an affected world
by many conflicts and too much
intolerance
It is a demonstration
that what at first seems
impossible if you persevere you can
return possible
even in Syria or Yemen or Sudan
from the south
the key
in the words of that great English poet
Tennyson is striving to find
and not give up
[Music]
several lessons can be derived from the
peace process in colombia 'I would like
share with the world
you have to prepare and advise
duly analyzing what failure in
previous attempts at peace in one's own
country and learning from the successes and
failures of other peace processes
you have to set a negotiating agenda
realistic and concrete solution
matters directly related to
conflict and that does not intend to cover
all the problems of the nation
we must advance the negotiations with
discretion and confidentiality so that
do not become a media circus
sometimes to reach peace is
necessary to fight and dialogue at the same
weather
a lesson I learned from another winner
of the Nobel Prize isaac Rabbin
you have to be willing to take
difficult decisions audacious many
many times unpopular to achieve
the ultimate goal of peace
this meant in my case
get closer to government of neighboring countries
with whom I had and I still have deep
ideological differences
Regional support is essential for
the political solution of any war
asymmetric nowadays
and today fortunately all the countries of the
region are firm allies in the search
of peace that is the noblest purpose
of any society
we also achieved something very important that
was to agree a model of justice
transitional that allows us to obtain the
maximum of justice without sacrificing peace
I have no doubt that this model will be
one of the great legacies of the process
of peace of colombia
Ladies and Gentlemen
there is a war - in the world and it is
Colombia
and this is precisely what we celebrate
today in oslo the same city that hosted
the start of the public phase of
talks with the FARC in October
of the year 2012
and I must say that I feel honored
and at the same time humble to join the
line of brave and inspiring
men and women
since 1901 they have received the most
prestigious of the awards
the peace process in colombia 'I say it
with deep gratitude
It is a fortunate synthesis of what
we have learned from them
peace efforts in the Middle East
in Central America in South Africa in Ireland
from the north whose artificers have received
this award showed us the way
to advance in a custom-made process
from Colombia
we also picked up the legacy of jody
Williams and the international campaign for
the prohibition of antipersonnel mines
equally winners of the nobel
after afghanistan colombia holds
the shameful record of being the country with
more mines and more mine victims in
all the world
our commitment is to have our
mine-free territory for the year
we have also received the support of
other winners like the European Union
president barack obama who have
committed to their countries to support the
crucial process of implementation of the
peace agreement in colombia '
and I can not pass up the opportunity
to reiterate today
a call that I have made to the world since
the summit of the americas of Cartagena
in the year 2012 and that led to a
special session of the general assembly
of the united nations in April of
present year
I mean the urgent need to
rethink the world war against
drugs a war in which colombia has
been the country that more dead and more
sacrifices has put
we have we have the moral authority to
affirm that after decades of struggle
against the drug trade the world has not
managed to control this scourge that
feeds violence and corruption in
our entire global community
the agreement with the FARC includes the
commitment of this group to break
any link with the business of the
drugs and to help fight it
but drug trafficking is a problem
global and requires a global solution
that starts from an undeniable reality
the war on drugs has not been
won is not winning
it does not make sense to imprison a peasant
who sows marijuana
when for example today is legal
produce it and consume it in 8 states of
The USA
the way in which the
war against drugs is equal or
even more harmful than all wars
together that today are fought in the world and
it's time to change our strategy
in colombia they have also inspired us
the initiatives of malaga
the youngest recipient of the Nobel prize
we know that only by forming
minds through education we can
transform reality
we are the result of our
thoughts
thoughts that create our words
words that create
our actions
that's why we have to change from
in
we have to change the culture of
violence for a culture of peace and
coexistence we have to change the
culture of exclusion by a culture
of inclusion and tolerance
and speaking of coexistence we have also
learned from the former vice president of usa
to golf and the intergovernmental panel
about climate change in its endeavor
for saving the planet
It's good to say that the
end of the conflict in Colombia the country
most biodiverse from around the world by
square kilometer
will bring important dividends
environmental
by replacing illicit crops with
legal crops
the deforestation generated to plant
coca will decrease
in addition, millions of
barrels of oil to our rivers and
our seas because of attacks on
the oil infrastructure
in conclusion the peace process of
Colombia that is rewarded today in Oslo is the
synthesis and the result of many
positive efforts that have been made
through history and around the
world and that have been valued and
exalted by this committee of the nobel
Dear friends
in a world where citizens take
the most crucial decisions for them
and for their nations pushed by the
fear and despair we have to
make the judgment possible the certainty of
the hope
in a world where wars and
conflicts are fueled by hatred and
the prejudices
we have to find the path of
forgiveness and reconciliation
in a world in which the
borders to immigrants is attacked
minorities and excludes the
different we have to be able to
live with diversity and appreciate the
way it enriches our
societies
to the
at the end of the day we are all beings
humans
for whom we are believers we are all
Children of God
we are part of this magnificent adventure
what it means to be alive and populate this
planet
nothing differentiates us in the essence
neither the color of the skin nor the creeds
religious nor political ideologies
nor are sexual preferences just
facets of the rich diversity of being
human
awaken the creative capacity for
good
for the construction of peace that
resides in each soul
in the end
we are one people and one race
of all the colors of all the
beliefs of all preferences
our town is called the world and
our race is called humanity
if we understand this
if we make it part of our
individual and collective conscience
then we can cut the root itself
of conflicts and wars
in 1982
34 years ago the efforts began
to achieve the peace of colombia
through dialogue
that same year
in stockholm
Gabriel Garcia Marquez
who was my ally in the search for
peace together with the former president felipe
gonzález that today accompanies us
he received the Nobel prize for literature and
I speak
spoke of a new and devastating utopia
of the life
where the strains sentenced to 100 years
of loneliness
have finally and forever a
second opportunity
on earth
today colombia
my beloved country
is enjoying this second
opportunity
and I thank you
to the Norwegian Nobel committee because in
This time
they not only awarded an effort for peace
you helped make it possible
the sun of peace shines at last in the
sky of colombia and that its light illuminate
to the whole world thank you very much
[Applause]